which joining me now is Louise Jones
head of intelligence at McKenzie
intelligence services so welcome to you
so as we saw there a real focus on the
targeting of Civilian infrastructure
Louise how is that going to affect the
war as the winter goes on yeah so I
think it's important to understand these
events in the context of just how long
this war is likely to go on for it
easily lasts for many months if not
years and so therefore the resilience of
Ukraine is really important and the
sustainability of its ability to keep up
the war effort now these uh this
targeting of Civilian infrastructure
will have a real impact on the Ukrainian
economy Ukrainian industry and we'll
make it harder for them therefore to
have this resilience it'll also make
conditions a lot harder for civilians
with respect to their ability to you
know prepare food properly to live in
heated homes and then you'll start to
see that this could easily have a
knock-on effect on the health of the
population their morale which again just
puts further strain possibly on
Ukraine's infrastructure and what Russia
is hoping that therefore this will
undermine the determination of the UK
training is to keep up their defense
however as we've seen from the very
beginning Russia is always completely
miscalculated the determination of the
ukrainians to remain independent so
slightly this is just another
miscalculation there well yes and one
focus of course in recent weeks has been
Hassan so it gives us up to date with
what's going on there now and how are
Ukraine able to to to gain ground are
they able to make any progress yes so uh
Hessel was retaken by the ukrainians in
in mid-november and really it was a it
was a difficult City for the Russians to
defend because of the Nipa river that
runs alongside it this meant that the
Russians really had uh pockets of
Defenders that were isolated from their
main Logistics Chain by the river now
whereas this gave the advantage to the
ukrainians retaking hairs on it then
therefore turns to their disadvantage if
they try and Advance further east in the
river because they will face exactly the
same problem and the Russians know this
so um they've therefore really focused
on having a blocking offense effect on
these roots that head east and south
from Herson they've started to have some
very fortified dug in positions they've
got anti-vehicle measures on these
routes such as Dragon's Teeth on the
roads and that's very crucial because
this Central route here is the main
route to Crimea which is of totemic
significance for the ukrainians they
would love to be able to head straight
for Crimea and retake that back however
the Russians know they just need to have
a very credible block effect here and
really Ukraine will struggle to make it
across the river and Advance further
along this axis the ukrainians will
probably be forced for the for their
next move to have to cross the NEPA
River much higher up to the north and
Advance South through zaporizia so
they've they've got some operational
decisions to make there and very briefly
what's the situation in the donbass and
particularly around bakmud yeah so the
Russians are attempting with back the
same tactics that they tried with
mariopol and several Donetsk they're
essentially trying to encircle the town
isolate the Ukrainian Defenders and then
take it that way however they're not
being very successful with this the
ground is not conducive to Rapid
maneuver so really the size here people
down in trenched wolfess although the
Russians have made a very very slight
progress towards the South and they're
really no further on with this
particular strategy and it's the same
story for the ukrainians trying to
advance through savata and criminal
they're really struggling to to make any
ground there Louise thanks very much
indeed thank you